Even before the first Covid-19 vaccine was
around in Germany in December 2020 – protests
against the jab had already started!
At Germany’s largest demonstration, over
30,000 people gathered to speak up against looming
vaccinations and anti-covid restrictions.
They kept going throughout the
pandemic – loud and big!
The majority of Germans couldn’t wait to get
vaccinated – But there is a significant minority
of sceptics who have so far refused the jab.
The many burdens of the Covid-19 pandemic
have caused divisions, split up
friendships and even families.
In this video I want to find out:
How did we get here? Why are some
people sceptical of vaccinations? And how
should we react to this scepticism?
In order to answer these questions,
let’s look into some history books.
Anti-Vaxx movements are as old
as vaccinations themselves.
In 1796 the English physician Edward Jenner
developed what today is called the first
vaccination. It was against smallpox - an
illness that killed tens of thousands each
year in Europe alone at the time.
Also, common back then: cowpox. Jenner
observed that people who had previously
had cowpox were immune to smallpox.
The physician took fluid from a blister of
a woman infected with cowpox and scratched
it into the skin of a young boy.
Six weeks on, Jenner infected the
boy with smallpox – but the kid didn’t
get sick. The immunization had worked.
An important side note: the word vaccination
comes from the Latin word “Vacca”, meaning cow.
The medical revolution saved countless
lives. But at the time, it triggered fear
and scepticism in the United Kingdom - and
when it came to Germany, there as well.
History shows us: Scepticism against
vaccinations has always been there.
When we look at the situation
today, we can still see it:
about one in four people in Germany is
still unvaccinated – although the jabs
have been around for more than a year.
I asked myself – why do so many people still
decide not to get vaccinated today?
Are they scared of something?
Sabine Schroeder
doesn’t deny the existence of Covid-19.
She is a nurse in a Covid ward herself.
But she is also an alternative healer and
believes that vaccinations are unnatural
and is scared of alleged side-effects.
A relatively big group of vaxx sceptics in
Germany shares Sabine Schröder’s opinion.
A movement of people that also believes
in alternative medicine or esoterics.
Supporters assume that diseases don’t happen
randomly. On the contrary: They believe they
mark disbalances between body, mind and spirit.
Some people therefore decide not to get
vaccinated in order to keep this balance.
The group is particularly strong in Germany,
Austria and the German-speaking part of
Switzerland. When Germany’s vaccination drive
slowed down in summer 2021, even foreign
media-outlets reported on the movement.
Not everyone in Germany who decides against the
jab believes solely in alternative medicine.
There is a variety of reasons. For example this
physiotherapist, who wants to stay anonymous.
She opposes the idea of compulsory vaccinations.
Some people simply question the effectiveness
of Covid 19 vaccines despite scientifically
proven evidence. Like this young man
who also wants to stay anonymous.
Speaking to unvaccinated people helped me
get a sense for their individual reasons.
And I also realized:
There is a lot of misinformation around.
So to get the full picture, I spoke to
scientists from the University of Erfurt.
And their results confirmed my impression:
There is not just ONE reason to
refuse the jab.The group is diverse.
Nevertheless, the researchers were
able to identify 5 main reasons.
Number one: Confidence
People in this group question the safety and
the effectiveness of Covid-19 vaccinations.
They also distrust the
health care system in general
The 2nd reason: Complacency
This group tends to overestimate
their own immune system and underestimate
the risk of a severe Covid-19 infection.
Three: Constraints
People in this group believe
in the effectiveness of the jab but feel that
it takes too much time and effort to get it.
Four: Calculation
They consciously evaluate
the benefits and the risks of a vaccination.
They are particularly prone to fake news spread o
And the last one: Collective Responsibility
These people don’t question the jab, but they rely
on others to get it. They don’t feel the social
responsibility to get vaccinated themselves.
These 5 reasons don’t stand alone –
they can overlap and come together.
Looking at scepticism from
different angles, one realizes:
reasons to refuse the jab are complex, and they
have always been part of the story of vaccination.
The question is now: Do we just
have to accept this scepticism?
Do we need compulsory vaccinations?
Or are there other solutions?
Germany discusses plans for
mandatory Covid vaccinations.
Opinions on the topic vary. The country’s
health minister supports the idea.
Others emphasize the potential danger behind
the measure: a crack in social cohesion.
Aversion and annoyance have already grown
in the last two years of the pandemic,
experts observed.
The ever-changing Covid 19 restrictions,
varying regulations across German states,
and inconsistent information provided by
authorities are said to be influencing
this trend.
Additionally,
social cohesion has been affected by lockdown
measures and limited personal contact.
Should the threat of Covid-19 decline soon,
then the anger on boths sides might also fade
away. And once people get their social lives
back, social cohesion can surely improve.
And when the long-term effects of the
pandemic become visible in society,
we might well need new ways to repair this unity.
you